so I'm gonna start with a little love
story I fell in love in 2009 I fell in
love with gos concurrency model at a
tutorial taught by Rob Pike you see I've
been programming in distributed systems
in C++ at Google for several years and I
thought of concurrency in terms of
callbacks and locks and thread pools and
go introduced me to a new way of
thinking about my programs so for
example I had a couple of libraries for
reading and writing data and replicated
big tables like a large-scale
distributed storage systems and each of
my libraries for reading and writing was
seven hundred lines of twisty callback
written C++ as I decided to try
converting them to go and I was able to
get them down to under a hundred lines
and the code was so much clearer and it
made the concurrent algorithm so much
simpler to understand that I was
actually able to combine them and this
to me was a revelation after that
experience I began contributing to the
go libraries inside Google and I joined
the team full-time in 2011 to make go a
production language while my work has
focused on scale and go with larger
systems and teams my love of the
language is always centered around its
concurrency model today I want to talk
to you about how studying real world
systems can help us become better go
programmers go was my first practical
introduction to CSP the concurrent
communicating sequential processes model
for me the real charm in this model is
how it mirrors the real world I live in
New York City a place that's constantly
striving to scale with increasing
population and tourism
I see concurrency and communication in
the myriad systems that keep the city
running I'll ride the subway to work I'm
reminded daily of the system's limited
capacity and variable latency and every
election day I'm reminded the massive
parallel computation we run to sum up a
few very important numbers we see
concurrency and contention throughout
this process and repeated aggregation
and communication as we work towards the
final totals but most of all I see
concurrency in services and systems that
serve requests that need to deliver
results quickly and reliably to handle
incoming load gracefully and scale to
meet the city's ever grow
demands today I'm going to present a
simulation written go of one real-world
system a coffee shop I created a
simulation to explore a few properties
of services latency throughput
contention and utilization I evaluated
several implementations of the coffee
shop and go each one mapping to a
slightly different real-world scenario I
hope to show you the power and goes
model and what we can learn about system
dynamics with this simulation the
simulator is a kind of benchmark harness
that exercises various implementations
and measures their performance this
diagram shows the goroutines and
channels that form the harness the first
stage generates load in this case being
customers for the coffee shop the second
stage executes the function being
measured in our case and order a coffee
and weight function this stage measures
how long the function takes to execute
and reports that duration to the final
girl routine which aggregates the
results we vary the number of goroutines
in the second stage which you can think
of us a number of people requesting a
coffee simultaneously and will vary the
function being executed by that stage to
explore the design space and find the
best performing coffee shop our order
coffee and weight function makes a latte
and our simulation this happens in four
steps step 1 grind the coffee beans step
2 make espresso using the grounds step 3
steam the milk and step 4 combine the
espresso in the milk to make the latte
by default each of these steps uses CPU
for 1 milliseconds and that's a full CPU
burn nothing else can run on that CPU at
that time so if we do the 4 steps in
sequence the total time to prepare the
latte is 4 milliseconds this code shows
the ideal brew function which runs the
four steps and returns the latte the
first step grinds the coffee using the
grinder and returns the grounds the
second step prepares the coffee using
the espresso machine and the grounds
the third step steams the milk using the
steamer and the final step makes the
latte using the coffee and milk these
two shorts charts show the performance
of our coffee shop as we vary the number
of CPUs from 1 to 6 in the ideal
implementation we can prepare as many
lattes in parallel as our CPUs can
handle so with one CPU
we can prepare one latte in four
milliseconds our throughput or rather
brew put is 250 lattes per second so
just wait this is the starting point on
the left-hand chart throughput skills
linearly with more CPUs so it's six CPUs
we get 1,500 lattes per second on the
throughput chart higher values are
better the right-hand chart shows the
median time required required to make a
latte the cafe au latency stays flat at
4 milliseconds on this chart lower
values are better we'll return to charts
like these throughout the talk to
compare our implementations
unfortunately our Adeel coffee shop
isn't too realistic in a real coffee
shop each of these three steps requires
a specific machine a grinder for the
grinding the coffee machine coffee beans
and espresso for making the espresso and
a steamer for steaming the milk in the
simulation code these machines are real
data structures that track the latency
for each stage just as it would not work
for multiple people to use the same
machine simultaneously it is a race for
multiple goroutines to call ad on the
same machine data structure
simultaneously and indeed if we run the
ideal implementation with multiple CPUs
and enable the race detector we get a
runtime error indicating the data race
so our first lesson is remember to test
with the race detector but you all knew
that already there's another useful tip
here if you create a simulation and go
you can use the race detector to check
that you're synchronizing access to
shared resources properly so how can we
prevent multiple goroutines from
accessing the same machine
simultaneously one way would be to put a
lock on the entire set of machines this
would be again to use a real world
analogy like putting all the coffee
machines in a small kitchen and only
allowing one person in at a time the
code on the right implements this whole
kitchen locking scenario when we measure
this scenario we find the exact opposite
of the ideal scenario throughput stays
flat at 250 lattes per second and
latency grows linearly with CPUs why
because there's no way for more than one
person to make a coffee at a time each
additional CPU is another person waiting
in line
make their coffee when the enth person
joins a line they must make wait four
milliseconds for each of the preceding
and minus one people of course we know
we can do better than this because we
see better in the real world in the real
world different people can use different
machine simultaneously as long as the
kitchen is big enough one person can use
a grinder while another mix espresso and
a third can steam their milk now this
isn't a traditional coffee shop with
Britta's behind the counter this is more
like a self-serve Coffee kitchen where
anyone can use any machine we'll come
back to the Bristow model later Ingo we
can implement this scenario using a
mutex for each machine a girl routine
locks the grinder mutex then uses a
grinder that unlocks it it then it locks
the espresso machine mutex and so on so
now instead of locking the whole kitchen
for four milliseconds we're just locking
each of the three machines for one
millisecond each the fourth phase making
the latte where the coffee and milk
doesn't need any locks at all now our
throughput and latency curves look more
interesting as we add CPUs up to four
CPUs throughput grows linearly and
latency stays flat just like in our
ideal implementation but with the fifth
and seek sixth CPUs throughput stays
flat and latency starts increasing
somewhat like our whole kitchen locking
scenario well what's happening here when
there's just three people in the kitchen
each takes their turn at the Machine and
moves on beyond three each additional
person needs to wait their turn because
all the machines are in use notice
though that the latency is increasing
much more slowly than in the whole
kitchen locking scenario this is because
the pipeline of people making coffee is
advancing each millisecond instead of
every four milliseconds we enabled
greater parallelism and increased our
throughput by minimizing the time we
held the lock on any one resource we're
also avoiding holding any locks at all
during the fourth phase as there's no
contention on any shared resource in
that step but why does throughput
flatten after four CPUs to understand
what's happening let's model how this
coffee making schedules onto CPUs the
first coffee runs on CPU one taking one
millisecond per stage
the second coffee Waits one millisecond
to use the grinder and then can proceed
in parallel on CPU to the third coffee
waits again for the grinder and proceeds
on CPU three and same with the fourth
copy on CPU four but what about the
fifth by the time the grinder is free
CPU one is free again so it can run
there it can't possibly start sooner
because the grinder is fully utilized
this pattern continues indefinitely
there's no way for this system to use
more than four CPUs in parallel because
of contention on the grinder that is why
the throughput of the system flattens at
a thousand lattes per second 4 CPUs
running at 250 lattes per second each so
given this structural limit how can we
increase the performance of our system
let's think about the real world again
if you wanted to make a coffee and saw
people lining up to use the machines
what would you do well it depends on how
long the line is
you might just give up but let's assume
you really need that coffee the problem
is that our critical resources of the
three machines are running at capacity
you'd probably find another place to get
your coffee and this suggests the remedy
if there were a second set of machines
or a second coffee shop more people
could make coffee simultaneously so what
happens if we double our machines so we
have two grinders two espresso machines
and two steamers let's simulate this and
find out one way we can implement this
scenario one go is by creating a buffer
channel of size 2 for each machine type
and putting 2 machines on each Channel
now instead of locking in mutex the girl
routine receives from the channel to get
access to one of the two machines when
it's done with the Machine the goroutine
sends machine back on the channel with
two sets of machines we see ideal
performance up to 6 CPUs throughput
increases linearly and latency stays
flat here's another way to compare the
performance of the implementations we've
seen so far the chart on the Left shows
the throughput of each implementation
when running with 6 CPUs the chart on
the right shows their latency
distributions rectangles indicate the
middle 50% of latencies while the
vertical lines indicate the middle 90%
so for example the locking scenario the
whole kitchen locking
scenario has a throughput of just 250
lattes per second and the latency span
between 22 and 25 milliseconds with most
of them falling between 23 and 24
milliseconds you can see that the whole
kitchen locking is much lower through
but much higher latency than our ideal
implementation the fine-grained locking
implementation does better peaking at
around a thousand lattes per second due
to the structural limits we saw earlier
we overcome the structural limit by
adding more capacity that is more coffee
machines with two of each machine we
achieve ideal performance doubling again
to four of each machine which is that
final column it gains us nothing because
we've maxed out our six CPUs
now our CPUs are the limiting factor so
to increase performance further we'll
need more CPUs so in each case our
limiting factor is moved so so far we've
simulated a shared coffee kitchen where
each person making coffee takes turns
using a shared set of machines but
that's not what we see in the real world
in the real world we usually see a small
number of Britta's operating the
machines this is more efficient because
there are fewer people moving around the
kitchen and Marisa's operate the
machines much more quickly than the
average customer the next simulation
i'll present is a coffee assembly line
in which one person operates each
machine the first person operates the
grinder passes the grounds to the second
person who makes the espresso and so on
let's see how this is implemented didn't
go finally we have some goroutines and
channels in this pipeline we have three
stages a grinder a presser and a steamer
the grinder receives no new orders on
the orders Channel grinds the beads adds
grounds to the order passes it along to
next stage the presser makes espresso
using the grounds and passes the coffee
along to the steamer the steamer steamed
some milk and passes it back to the
goroutine waiting on the order that girl
routine combines the coffee and milk to
make the latte when we look at this
performance of this pipeline this is the
green line it looks a lot like the fine
grain Locke implementation the latency
is identical but the throughput is
slightly less until we reach six CPUs
why is this latency is the time it takes
to run each of the four stages in
sequence so it takes makes a sense that
it would remain the same in the locking
and pipeline implementations but the
pipeline's throughput is less because it
is
not utilizing the three contended
machines as efficiently here's the real
world analogy to help you understand
this consider what happens when the
person using the grinder finishes
grinding the beans in the locking
implementation that person steps away
from the grinder and starts waiting for
the espresso machine someone else can
start using the grinder immediately but
in the pipeline implementation the
person grinding the beans has to wait to
hand off the grounds to the person
making the espresso before they can
start the next grind if the second
person is busy making the espresso the
first person just stands there holding
out the grounds this is a blocked
channel send in our implementation and
this leaves the grinder idle under
utilizing our resources of course in the
real world the person would just set the
grounds down on the counter and start
grinding more beans for the next coffee
that counter space allows for different
stages of the pipeline to stay busy even
if they're a little out of sync and in
the real world where grinding beans or
making espresso might take more or less
time due to natural variants we need
that flexibility and we needed in our
computer systems as well because there's
natural variants in these systems so how
do we model that counter space and go we
do so by adding buffers to the channels
that connect our pipeline these buffers
absorb the variance between stages and
so increase throughput and utilization I
tested pipelines with buffer size 1 and
buffer size 10 the lines are overlapping
on the charts both of these buffer
pipelines outperform the unbuffered
pipeline achieving the optimal
throughput of a thousand lattes per
second this is because they eliminate
the requirement for the stages to
proceed in sync and so allowed more work
to proceed in parallel but while we see
a benefit with buffering it's important
to keep those gains in perspective these
charts should compare all the
implementations we've seen plus 2 multi
pipe scenarios the multi pipe scenarios
run multiple copies of the buffered
coffee pipelines much like the multi
scenarios use multiple copies of the
various machines you can think of multi
pipe 2 as a world with two coffee shops
next door to each other what we've seen
these charts have said the differences
between fine-grained locking in the
various pipelines the middle for bars
the differences are all pretty minor
two big gains came from structural
changes the first was moving from a
whole kitchen lock to fine grained per
machine locks this reduced the time
spent in any one critical section so
that more work could run in parallel the
second was recognizing when our existing
resources were fully utilized and adding
more capacity in the multi machine
scenarios this allowed us to max out our
six CPUs the CPUs are now our limiting
resources if we want to get more
throughput we'll need to add more CPUs
to run our simulation in preparing for
this talk I tried many more scenarios
than the ones I've shown you so far I
tried changing the number of stages
changing their duration and adding
random noise I tried making the steamed
milk stage run in parallel with the
other stages and what's remarkable is
how little any of that mattered most of
the changes had only small effects on
performance but the structural changes
provided major gains the lesson is to
identify and remove the structural
barriers to parallelism in your system
removing these barriers will help your
system scale we did this today by
reducing the time spent in critical
sections we did it again by adding more
replicas of contended resources and we
did this with buffering which allowed
upstream pipeline stages to proceed
without blocking on downstream stages
and while we focused on the benefits of
these changes it's important to remember
they also have costs in particular
increased resource use I also encourage
you to take inspiration from real-world
systems try to understand why they are
the way they are these insights will
help you understand structural
performance issues and help you discover
new designs one last thing I encourage
you all to download the simulator and
play with it the code is straightforward
less than a thousand lines of go for
everything try some more scenarios dig
into the results using ghost profiling
tools the exception tracer is a
particularly useful tool here or perhaps
try modeling a new real-world system and
go you'll learn more about how that
system works and you'll learn a lot
about NGO itself thank you
[Applause]